well it's an autobiography my mark
combined with a history of American
education reform over the last 50 years
and indeed intersecting the
autobiographical side of it with the
historical side of it was the challenge
in writing the book I just finally felt
like it was time to tell sort of how
things had come to be the way they are
and that it would be a lot more
interesting if I intertwined that with
how I came to be the way I am and so the
intersection of the personal story and
the history is the theme of the book
along with a lot of very personal stuff
like my own kids education and the
topics like that about 1967 when I went
enrolled in a doctoral program at the
Harbor dead school that was actually a
policy program that was pretty much the
year after i tried full-time high school
teaching and decided that my perch in
this field was not going to be retail it
was going to be wholesale and that meant
trying to alter the system rather than
try to be a a cog in it and that was a
graduate student aged about 24
well mazama at figure in my graduate
education and then about the first 15
years of my life and three different
jobs was Pat Moynihan late Senator
Daniel Patrick Moynihan who was newly
arrived at Harvard as a professor of
Education and Urban Affairs at the very
same year I was looking for a doctoral
advisor and he didn't have any doctoral
students and I had met him before I'd
met him when he came in guest lectured
in undergraduate courses and when I went
to visit him once in Washington when he
was working on the war on poverty but
basically he I persuaded him to be my
doctoral advisor and then a year to two
years later Nixon asked him to go to
work at the White House as the Urban
Affairs guy keep in mind this is 1968-69
the cities are ablaze the RFK and Martin
Luther King assassinations it just
happened looked like the country was
going to hell in a handbasket and Nixon
who didn't really like Harvard
professors hired both Henry Kissinger
and Pat Moynihan to come from Harvard to
sit in the west wing of the White House
and help the early days the Nixon
administration Moynihan needed to put
together a staff of helpers to assist
him and asked me and a couple of his
other former students as well as a
couple of grown-ups if we would come and
be part of his team at the White House
and then I went on in various Moynihan
incarnations ending with being his
legislative director during his first
term in the in the US Senate about ten
years later that was the sort of
formative experience my early
professional life and but other things
were going on as well Lyndon Johnson was
declaring war on poverty and saying that
education was the way to get in poverty
in America the way to equalize
opportunity all of this sounded like
something pretty exciting and and pretty
important I had already become a kind of
a volunteer work social reformer as an
undergraduate and I knew I didn't want
to join the family law firm in Ohio and
i thought that education might be the
thing to do and
one thing led to another what is why
everybody should read trouble because
all of us is in there I the Moynihan was
a disciple as it were of the late james
coleman the great sociologist whose
major study of equality of educational
opportunity had come out right about
that time and what the coleman report as
it's known began to do in American
education in the mid-60s and we're still
living with the consequences of this
forty years later is to begin to to
switch our attention from what goes into
schools to what comes out of schools
from inputs and resources and good
intentions on the one hand to student
achievement and actual school
effectiveness on the other hand but was
a revolution in our approach to
understanding and thinking about and
making policy for education and the
education profession didn't like it at
all because it was the beginnings of
what we now call results-based
accountability or standards-based reform
and it began to say let's actually
measure and look at what the what the
school is accomplished rather than how
much money per kid we spend or how many
programs we've got in the school so
Moynihan brought that consciousness and
a major significant book reanalysis of
Coleman's data out into public view and
then he put that idea and basically into
the mouth of Richard Nixon and so
Nixon's first major message to Congress
on education I in the in early nineteen
seventy eight Coleman like reasoning to
bear on federal policy in education and
this began to make a lot of sense to me
that what we were interested in was
whether things were working not just
whether the intentions were good and I
was having a lot of simultaneous
experience with programs and schools
that often were not working and fiddling
with the inputs didn't seem to change
anything and adding another program
didn't seem to change anything so I
think the great shift there have been
two great shifts in American education
over the last forty years but one of
them has
and from inputs to results and that was
very much moynihan picking up on Coleman
and it certainly had an enormous
influence on me and my work